in a fractured divided world it's nice
to know there is one thing we can all
agree on
the calendar no matter your politics or
your religion we can all agree that the
year is 2021
right well not so fast according to a
german historian
the year is actually 1724. he says our
calendar is a lie
and a big chunk of the middle ages never
happened sounds crazy
well he says he can prove it let's find
out why
[Music]
in 1991 german historian eribert ilig
and a few colleagues
proposed a radical idea we aren't living
in the 21st century
we're actually living in the 18th
century this is called the phantom time
hypothesis
which says that back in 1000 a.d there
was a conspiracy between the church and
the holy roman emperor to change the
calendar
the years 614 through 9 11 were
completely made up
those 300 years just didn't happen so
all that history you learned about
charlemagne and the middle ages
completely fabricated in fact elix says
that charlemagne was specifically
designed as propaganda to support the
calendar change
to give the emperor and the pope more
power an elite group of people
manipulating the entire world to gain
power
what else is new oh you believe this one
huh three words
yeah tin foil cat yeah i thought you'd
say that
okay let's look at the calendar and see
if we can figure out what the heck is
going on with phantom time
so why do we even use the calendar we do
throughout most of human history
different cultures use
different calendars some were based on
seasons some on the sun
some on the moon some were just
arbitrary as the romans gobbled up more
territory
these different calendars made commerce
complicated so in 45 bce
julius caesar proposed a standard
calendar to be used by the empire he
proposed commanded there you go the
julian calendar was based on a tropical
year
also known as a solar year or one earth
orbit around the sun
and a year was 365.25 days with leap
years
but a solar year is actually a little
shorter than they thought
it's really 365.24219 days
that's a difference of 11 minutes now 11
minutes isn't much
but the julian calendar was losing a
full day every 128
years and after 1500 years the slippage
was noticeable
the church really liked easter to land
on march 21st the spring equinox
but in the 1500s easter was landing
around march 11th
this irritated pope gregory yeah an
irritated pope
isn't good for anybody that's true the
church announced the change
a year would be 365 days with an extra
day
added to every year divisible by four
and a few other rules to keep things in
sync but that's the gist
so in 1582 the gregorian calendar was
adopted and 10 of the lost days were
added back to the calendar
you went to bed on october 4th and woke
up on october 15th
and that's where we've been ever since
but wait a minute
losing a day every 128 years means the
old calendar was off by almost
13 days but the pope only removed 10
days
10 days only accounts for about 1200 of
the 1500 years that had passed
since the old calendar but 10 days did
indeed bring the new calendar into sync
with the equinox
that shouldn't have worked that means
the new calendar was adjusted 300 years
earlier
this is the big question was pope
gregory aware that he made a
mathematical error
or was there something more sinister
happening herbert illig believes pope
gregory didn't make a mistake
he believes the pope intentionally
covered up a conspiracy that happened
centuries earlier
so ilig started looking for clues in the
middle ages
and eventually he found them
arabert illig was convinced this
three-day discrepancy
wasn't a mistake he suspected pope
gregory was compensating for something
that happened
in the catholic church centuries earlier
it looked focused on the dark ages and
noticed there was one specific period of
time
that had a noticeable lack of records
and artifacts
6 14 to 9 11. this was the time before
charlemagne's rule and right up until
the
start of the atonian dynasty that led
him to suspect number one
holy roman emperor otto the third illick
believed that otto iii
pope sylvester ii and possibly byzantine
emperor constantine vii
had a secret plan to move themselves
from the 7th century
to the 10th century so otto can rule in
the new millennium
illeg noted that the roman empire kept
detailed records right up until the year
when the dark ages supposedly began but
then written history basically vanishes
for 300 years
also the architecture of the year 476
was almost identical to that of the year
with virtually no progress now for
perspective this would be like
us living in thatched roof dirt floor
houses today
the technological advancements also seem
to stop for these 300 years
the roman empire had aqueducts and
indoor plumbing the renaissance gave us
da vinci copernicus and the discovery of
the new world
but for the missing 300 years there was
virtually no scientific advancement
european castles were also a problem
illig found plenty of castles built
right up until the year 600 and plenty
built after the year 1000
but there's no trace of anything built
in between now illick had found a
document that claimed that almost 1700
structures were built during the missing
years
but when he traced those structures he
noticed 97
of them were gone no evidence they ever
existed
the list was a forgery a fake that
intended to rewrite history
but certainly there would be archaeology
that would prove these years happened
right evidence of human settlements
actual human remains
yeah no no
in 1986 archaeologists noticed there was
very little evidence of medieval towns
during a certain period
there was a gap that lasted from 6 50 to
9 10.
specifically in germany not a single
discovery was attributed to this time
not a single one the only luminous
figure to come out of this time was
charles the great more widely known as
charlemagne
but according to the phantom time
hypothesis emperor charlemagne
never existed supporters of the phantom
time hypothesis note that nothing has
been preserved from the missing 300
years
no streets homes no artifacts and maybe
know charlemagne
illegal and others believe that otto iii
created charlemagne in his own image
and there are plenty of problems with
the history of charlemagne for instance
he seemed to have accomplished
too much for one guy charlemagne was an
astronomer
agriculturalist and architect but of his
46-year reign
he was at war all over the world for 44
of those years
yet he still found time to create a jury
system and over 100 new laws
he reformed the education system he
updated scripture
some say it would take four or five
lifetimes to accomplish all of this
yet charlemagne was somehow able to do
it illig and others conclude that the
only logical reason for this
is that charlemagne was made up and otto
had plenty of motive to give charlemagne
such a juicy resume since the atonians
manipulated their way into the holy
roman empire
they needed to give themselves a
backstory because of their association
with charlemagne
the atonians would be seen as heroes and
their rule would be legitimized
but if charlotte made in those 300 years
were a lie
otto iii needed the rest of the world
including the middle east and
asia to corroborate the lie maybe he did
illigan others claim that islamic record
keepers added events
and hundreds of years to their own
historical documents
which is why the christians jews and
byzantines all introduced new calendars
around the same time
the 10th century all for the sake of one
holy roman emperor's glory
and fame the phantom time hypothesis
what a great conspiracy but is it true
did charlemagne exist well he almost
certainly did
but was his resume exaggerated well it
almost certainly was
he was great at two things winning wars
and fathering children
he was a supporter of science the arts
the rule of law and certainly the church
but all of his non-military
accomplishments could be attributed to
the talented people he kept around him
still that's not a scientific rebuttal
of the phantom time hypothesis
but how about this haley's comment
haley's comet is visible on earth every
75 or 76 years
and records exist of it being seen as
far back as 475 bc
and all the way through the missing
centuries now there aren't a lot of
records of it in european history during
this time
but there are records of the comet in
chinese history
as to why there aren't a lot of records
from the dark ages the answer is more
obvious than illid considered
after the roman empire fell the entire
world was thrown into chaos and war
society's infrastructure pretty much
collapsed and in the middle ages
almost 95 percent of the world's
population was living in poverty
and less than five percent of people
even knew how to read there isn't a lot
of opportunity for art and science to
advance if the entire world is
struggling to not die of starvation
but what about pope gregory he really
did move the calendar by 10 days not 13.
so how do we account for the pope's
mathematical error turns out that illick
didn't have all the information
when historians looked into the date
change they learned that the 10-day
adjustment wasn't based on the start of
the julian calendar
in 45 bc actually the pope brought
easter back into sync after it had
already been moved
three days by the council of nicaea in
so 10 days was all that was needed three
days from nicaea
10 days from gregory that's your 13 days
now the vast majority of historians
consider this conspiracy to be debunked
but ill again others are sticking to
their story yeah i gotta respect that i
do
and i'll keep an eye on this and if
anything changes we'll do another video
but in the meanwhile
i'm going to consider the phantom time
hypothesis while a fantastic story
debunked
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files and if you had
fun or learned anything today
hit like and subscribe and share and
comment did all those things that a good
footage channel he told me to tell you
just then
all that stuff helps us out so much and
until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
you